personally i think it's a little bit
funny you know because he's calling us
terrorists yet we have six-year-old kids
out here playing hockey we have four or
five bouncy castles during the weekend
with hundreds of kids playing around in
bouncy castles i mean if that's a
terrace
there's a lot of people out there that
are a lot worse off you know
[Music]
well i think it's uh disgusting for any
leader of a country to vilify people for
exercising their democratic rate their
right to protest the right to
demonstrate peacefully i think it's
terrible
no i think it's uh he's just really
making a mockery out of himself more
than anybody else because people have
eyes what he's portraying is that that's
not what we're doing
right we're here and i've seen lots of
kids around
not cause no problems right
it's totally awful
these a racist himself right there's no
racism going on here he's said many
times publicly that he supports peaceful
protest
uh but except i guess when it disagrees
with what he believes or what narrative
that he wants people to follow as my
brother-in-law said he needs to be a man
and step up and just come out and talk
to us that's all we're asking
we're not trying to overthrow the
government we're not trying to ruin
democracy we're following democracy i
think he's treating us like a minority
would be treated you can walk around the
side of the car and see all the thank
you notes little kids
you know there's no
no racist drawings and no we're all
enjoying it
it's like the most beautiful thing
you've ever seen coming together across
all of canada